good afternoon everyone it's an honor
this is the new face of house Democratic
Leadership younger and more diverse
52-year-old Hakeem Jeffries will be the
first black American to lead a party in
Congress house Democrats
fight for the people
that's our story that's our Legacy
that's our values that's our commitment
as we move forward get stuff done
Catherine Clark will be his number two
as whip we as a team and as a caucus
reflect the diversity in the strength of
the American people
and that is where we are able to come
together around shared values and Pete
Aguilar a member of the Hispanic caucus
will be number three as house caucus
chair the Trio's Ascension marks a
generational change in the Democrats
house leadership replacing three
octogenarians led by Nancy Pelosi who
was leader for nearly two decades the
older Trio announced they'd resigned
from their current leadership roles
after Democrats lost control of the
house in the last election we'll never
see someone like speaker Pelosi ever
again in our lifetime
but her potential successor will be
history making in its own right
Jeffries will become House minority
leader when the newly elected elect
Congress can be convey January
enroll largely to run defense against
the new Republican majority we look
forward
to finding opportunities to partner with
the other side of the aisle
and work with them
whenever possible
but we will also push back against
extremism
whenever necessary
the new Republican House Majority is
expected to launch investigations into
President Joe Biden into his son Hunter
and other administrative officials with
Democrats still holding the majority in
the U.S Senate a divided Congress and
one that is gridlocked is nearly certain
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington